وفي مقابله مع الجزيره ايضا قالت مديره
مستشفى الامومه في ادلب اكرام حبوش ان
عددا من المستشفيات خرج عن الخدمه ما عمق
المعاناه القائمه اصلا في الشمال الغربي
لسوريا واضافت انه لم يدخل بعد اي شيء من
المساعدات او فرق الانقاذ من المعابر الى
الداخل السوري
نحن بالاصل عم نعاني من نقص شديد
بامكانيات وتراجع في الدعم في القطاع
الصحي في شمال غرب سوريا وخاصه بعد ازمه
اوكرانيا هلا انا
كقطاع نسائيه وتوليد بسبب انه قسم من
مشاكل
تقدم هاي الخدمه طلعت عن العمل مثل المشفى
الامومي في الدانه وباقي المشافي او
المشافي الاخرى فهذا الشيخ اللي عندنا ضغط
نحن على المشافع اللي لسه عم نقدم الخدمه
ضغط كبير من ناحيه انه المراجعين باعدادهم
الكبير اللي نحن ما فينا عم نحسن نقدم شيء
عم نحاول قدر الامكان يعني خدمه الولاده
والقيصرين امنهم اياها بس نحن بالنسبه لنا
قسم الحواضن ممتلئ وقسم حديثي الولاده
ممتلئ بس اذا بدنا نحكي على المشافي اللي
عم تقدم الجراحات والمشافه اللي عم يصير
عليها اسعاف الجرحى ومصابين
نحن بالاصل بالشمال غير سوريا عدد الاطباء
والمنشات قليله لحد الان المعابر ما دخل
منها ولا فريق انقاذ ولا دخل اي شيء من
المساعدات